to present the nominees for the  outstanding performance by an actor in a  supporting role there are two previous  Oscar winners and still champions Walter  Matthau and Liza Minnelli  nominees are  Melvin Douglas in being there  Robert Duvall in Apocalypse Now  Frederick forest and the rose  Justin Henry in Kramer vs Kramer  Mickey Rooney  and the winner is  Melvyn Douglas in being  the Academy congratulate smelvin Douglas  and accepts this award on his behalf  thank you  it is not Melvin Douglass's fault he's  not here tonight he was in a car pool  with Allen split  tonight the Academy honors with a  special Oscar a truly international  actor as incredible as it seems his  career began in 1933 and shows  absolutely no sign of waning his name  Sir Alec Guinness